[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's the best song I hear you I hear
you up in there um let me know if y'all
hear you hear me you hear people in the
chat this let me know what you get here
that I see you up in there
[Music]
I am Mike let's go above it let me know
if you hear me man
make sure okay cool I hear me somebody
on the re
everybody just talk for me I wanna make
sure I disagree yeah yo yo yo yo I'm
here I know
let me I can hear them talk is good
let's go out is what up what up what up
some goat talk it sounds good everybody
good
[Music]
[Music]
before I added these the mutism bike
business
[Music]
all right Mike with dis land I see that
[Music]
at a good ever with lambs go stop
[Music]
all right and we are live a little bit
of a Final Fantasy 7 remake spoiler cast
a little bit formal you know we got some
esteem the steam panel today you know so
I wanted to get some of the people who
are considered experts in the genre as
well as people who are very passionate
about the the franchise so we'll get
this thing rolling man
starting off Lord hog law the man of the
hour but the lawyer that everyone knows
it gate favorite gaming lawyer how you
doing sir first of all the definition of
fraud wrongful or criminal exception
intended to result in financial or
personal gain
whoa apropos of nothing of course I'm
doing great no no hitting meanings or
anything no no I thought I'd start out
with legal definition I appreciate that
very good to hear hole go spicy and
ready to talk man good to have you on
the panel we are gonna have a lot to say
about this game this inning so good to
have your own brother and of course we
have Law Lords of gaming dot Nets own
gravy one man how we do is it doing good
here represent one of the screens best
games in years
I agree we're gonna get into math it's
gonna be fun no bail brother had to have
you in a battle your passion for this
game and this franchise is very deep so
you know I had to have loads of game is
on
hexina builders and that's good stuff
you already know and of course I've been
on in a while my man from the online
arcade and one of our sitter
actually his game his Twitter tag is
actually Jay boorish Trice Jay Bari how
you doing sir
yeah you know what it's good man
definitely appreciate the invite I think
that's gonna be a good conversation in
here so yeah let's get it let's get him
and had to have Bari in here man a
passion rose thick so we got to do this
thing man and of course we got weapon
wheels on another Final Fantasy seven
lover like myself the immaculate BG was
going over all games HD how you doing
sir you know what's going on oh good to
be here today talks and Final Fantasy
no not to you for the invite oh you
already know brother yeah you know and I
don't know if attic is back from
whatever he's doing now we give him an
intro but hopefully he would join in
progress as discontinued but man we
gonna get right into it man so what I
wanted to do is break this thing up and
obviously we know about the ending it's
very controversial thing and you know we
want we got to get to that but what I
want to start what first is just
historically what Final Fantasy 7 means
to us you know I'm saying as a game as a
series and stuff like that so I'll start
off and then we'll pass it around so for
me you know final of our Final Fantasy
seven is a huge important deal to me as
a game for the first I think for the
first game for PlayStation as a RPG I
was kind of tricked I didn't know what
it was shout the king he had the
Japanese version early in New York and
we didn't know what to make of it and I
thought it was an action game and to be
honest once I got going I'm like wow
this is amazing this is on one of the
earlier JRPGs that I really attached
myself to I played JRPGs prior but I
never would consider myself a hardcore
RPG guy but when Final Fantasy sent it
to me it kind of normalized it to the
mainstream it made it cool you don't say
it to be a fan of these type of games
and I had a lot of my friends you know
I'm saying who would never buy games
like that come over to my house see the
game it would be like you know what is
that the cinematography the epicness the
boom bastard list of character designs
all that stuff resonated so that what
Final Fantasy 7 means to me and also is
really why I fell in love one of the
main reason why I fell in love with
PlayStation 1 it's one of my favorite
PlayStation so that's Deb I want to
bring it down and start off with arms
people have heard from for on this time
let's start off with our actually Jay
Bari I want to get I know how much on
twitter you rep Bueller's ed
so but I want a gift from you what Final
Fantasy 7 the game means to you
you know personally as a game alright so
yeah 157 it's pretty much like my
favorite game of all time I love this
game to death character story lower all
that stuff I'm just in general the whole
overall story of one of 87 I'm always
loved and you know our holy dear to my
heart
one of the reason is because not my
first Final Fantasy game that I played
but it's the first game where starters
do like strategy guys like French where
I sit up in the library and I read a
strategy guys I'm printing out old
school stuff today what we do we do it
yeah I mean it was no I was like like
huge in Italy I was a little kid about
this helping my friends like writing up
a little strategy guys for like you know
boss the secrets of stuff versus uhm but
yeah like this game the remake
everything this means a lot to me
because like I said my favorite game of
all time look like I love this game to
death make characters you already know
I'm a huge Cloud Strife feel you know
that's in my name for everything I
create every game carrots that creates
always something oh yeah man this is a
huge game no doubt that's what's up man
so let's get it to Lord heck demand was
given at all but taught me about your
journey with Final Fantasy 7
specifically what this game is franchise
means to you yeah and so my gateway to
seven was actually Crisis Core in the
PSP it's me when I was in middle school
and I decided to give it a go and I'd so
that's where like I really started
getting to like the whole world of Final
Fantasy 7 and the character Zack fares
my guy for me Zack salute and then uh I
really want to play the original by that
time didn't have PSN or least like for
ps3 like to play the classic so I
couldn't play the games my friend Jill
broke my PSP oh yeah after I played the
original Final Fantasy 7 just a download
and it's a struggle because I played
through it once and then my battery
crapped out on me so I had to read
download and play it again
mm-hmm same battery dropped out of the
PSP so all my saved I was corrupted oh
yes and I got to Cosmo Canyon so I
didn't really get to play through the
entire thing until it came on PSN and I
played it absolutely adored it loved the
characters the world of music
Ilse it was that game to get me to JRPGs
to play the classic normal trigger m61
so it's really it's an eerie place my
heart rough for what it does
story and characters it's it's
phenomenal free my favorite of all time
I feel you brother I feel you man
definitely resonate a lot of that
resonates with me as well let's get a
little BG in here man what's going on
Final Fantasy seven man what does it
mean to you the original two franchise
where is it hold a place for do you guys
hear me yes Final Fantasy is fun 57 is
one of those games were for me
like the gameplay was great but um you
know even though it's just you know a
lot of these RPGs is just technically
menu shuffling it's still you know a lot
of fun and one of the greatest things
about the game was like the depth of
that of the characters and how you know
each one of the characters was dealing
with something and each one of the
characters meant something you know like
cloud and his uh you know is his issue
with the insomnia and and you know his
his troubled past and everything like
that you know even going to CID you know
somebody who you know his character
would like renewal and trying to bring
you know something back a lot of the
characters just had depth you know even
the bad guy wasn't just a typical bad
guy and stuff like that like the game
had the had the depth that that like I
felt um when I play Metal Gear Solid 1
for the first time like snake and the
villains just not being you know did
this paper-thin character so like it's
just a really epic game and of course we
have Hogan law in the building I gotta
get home say I've never got a chance I
know we spoke briefly but I never got a
chance to ask what what the Final
Fantasy 7 you know series what does it
mean to you when it you know when it
first came out what is it
when is that hold that place it holds to
you sure absolutely
well you know I people that have been
following me on Twitter have seen me go
off for a couple days on this and some
people asked me if this game was
important to me and I you know I wanted
to take a step back and actually say you
know when you look at what I say what
you were about to hear me say and
definitely the passion I'm about to say
it with the tilt that everybody should
understand is that this is one of the
more important games in my life mmm
wouldn't active my life in gaming now I
don't know what everybody's Ages are
here but based on some of the content
you know I started with Final Fantasy 1
in terms of the Final Fantasy series
went through 2 & 3 which were actually 4
& 6
mm-hmm 6 was my favorite game of all
time a good long while III had a save
that I essentially kept at the opera
scene in 6 that I can play it from time
to time and just remind myself you know
what that felt like and that was the
game that really proved to me that this
medium that we love gaming video games
could tell stories that were so deep
that were so invested in that could
really touch us and could tell us
something about humanity even though
you're suplexing a train on the way
and so after Final Fantasy 6 which was
just this big big deal to me there was a
there was a pause before Final Fantasy 7
and I remember getting these kind of
leaked images out in game pros and a
GM's and saying oh yes and mid ger and
everything else and I got so excited and
this was the first game Final Fantasy 7
was the first game that I can really
remember that I bought myself didn't
have to ask the parents went out there
got a pre-order from the Electronics
Boutique that I kept my wall let's go in
order to just get through the tough days
I take it out look at it it was great I
remember being thrown into a pool by
some family and friends and I had to get
out and blow-dry the pre-order and I
wouldn't be able to get the game I mean
that's the space I was in for Final
Fantasy 7 and at that level of
expectation it came out and it beat it
and though Final Fantasy 7 is in my top
5 of all time it's one of my favorite
games I have been so excited about the
concept of a remake of bringing up that
game which I think the the rendered
style it didn't survive as well as some
of the other styles I go back to
something like 6 rather than 7 8 and 9
that might be just me but I was really
excited about seeing what they were
doing and then when they released the
demo of the bombing run you know a month
ago I was like they did it this is
unbelievable I'm there and then we've
got more to talk about but that's what
it means to me do huge huge but
definitely hear where you're coming from
one that definitely took me back with
those specific time peace quotes tours
and things of that nature man impressive
adding ran out you back you know me and
you have gone back and forth I've always
known you to be a Final Fantasy guy in
seven in particular so what does Final
Fantasy 7 mean to you well I think um
seven means a great deal I think the
whole franchise you know means more to
me than just seven like sevens like my
favorite game that's the funny thing
favorite it would have to be ten okay
ten or nine and one of those two okay
like I remember because I played eight
before I played seven and and then when
I played seven it was cuz back I didn't
have a memory card so I had to play the
whole goal with it on you know it was
just one of those things and I remember
like wanted them I don't remember which
one it was I got a memory card and I was
already in the middle of a playthrough
and no other than the PlayStation ones
you you had to reset them for it to
register a memory card so I couldn't
reset them anyway so what city what
technically with violet the Final
Fantasy III think it's the sole reason
I'm even in gaming mmm that's huge
that's a huge impact man one last thing
I know football what's that next time is
that um I think another thing for me
personally that really took it to the
next level don't know how this how you
guys feel about it but it's when I first
saw a summon for the first time what was
happening on that screen I remember
having Leviathan it was like what is
going on like this is a moon I played
yeah I'm pretty sure I played a demo
with it on it and the demo showed you
dear Diablo yeah well Hades Hades yeah I
remember so many that brawl it was like
what I mean it was such a powerful
feeling like I'm controlling this thing
and it is barri I heard you be like
summons name yeah I think we all hear
summon hunters - oh yeah seven years is
this amazing how you know the graphical
detail back then oh snap this is crazy
you know even when we got this chocobo
MOG the first time what was that fire
you know
then leading up to like one of my
favorite summers like Phoenix when I've
come all about homeless zero oh you know
Hades is one very important one you use
Ruby weapon well uh but yeah something's
amazing man no doubt man so let's get
into a mess obviously games out and we
have been touching we've been playing
all of us have ended it let's start we
don't do positive negative start
depositors first so I want to get let's
get our BG in now obviously I've had you
on IRP before I want to get your just a
positives about this particular we make
that you like what did they do well oh
man
the positive positive positive so just
to throw some stuff out that's all like
at the top of my mind I mean the voice
acting the voice acting is definitely
done good even in English voices you
know typically you know typically in
games like this I would probably turn on
the Japanese voice but the English
voices are good you know we got like
Asher from all-american you know Aerith
is this chick from YouTube and you know
Barrett is an accomplished you know
voice actor you know it's so crazy
because when I listen to me ever do from
Breaking Bad in there yeah yo I swear to
you when I listen to bear cuz you know
back then you know you had to create the
voices in your head facts you had could
you had known what everybody did it and
I swear to you that's exactly how I
pictured him sounding like men to the T
I'm like that's that's how he sounds and
then this guy did it and I'm like that
that's insane
yeah stand out the the battle system you
know just works so well especially when
see in the beginning of the game you're
kind of like you kind of like you know
you you start a stepping a little bit
just kind of tripping over you tripping
over the menu because you know it's real
time way and you might slip over the
menu or you just a little bit slow and
now you begin to like play the game you
know at this point you know playing
again on hard as you get further into
the game even on your first playthrough
now if you're playing it like you're
putting in fighting game commands where
you're not even like you don't even got
to think about it that much you just you
know you switching from Keira character
never do this would you be
you you going you shuffling through the
menu you know what something you're
gonna use you know what spell you're
gonna use you know what ability you want
to use so it just flows so fluidly once
you understand you know exactly you know
what sure what you're doing so I love
the battle the battle system you know
visuals are for the most part good we
obviously know it had there it is very
yeah it is very inconsistent but for the
nets are you by negative yeah and I know
it's just some people that try to over
blow it to make it seem like that's most
of the game or the majority of the game
for most of the game actually does look
good yeah right oh and that's that's
just the truth but you know like I said
it could go from Final Fantasy Advent
Children qualities ooh like something
you know a throwback from the ps1 know
like shout out to the bathroom textures
and we talk about they make the slums
look like the slums yeah accurate
representation yes yeah and I'm sure
we're gonna get into it like I do like
the the story the changes and how they
flesh now and how they've like put in
some how they but like they've added
some gaps you know like in the original
there were some things we had to assume
that happened in between
yeah so now they they're like oh this is
what happened and been between that we
are actually gonna show you how that you
know again it gets from point A to point
C because you know they skip B sometimes
in the original so you know all that
stuff I definitely you know love about
the game what about the process in a
song review so a lot in there what what
are the standout things about this
remake that you just love for me it was
especially after playing five easy 15
and playing through the Kingdom Hearts
series inspecting like really great
things how those franchises one thing I
thought to me about Fox and remake was
the world building it was for me
absolutely phenomenal and one most
immersive experiences I have had in a
video game since Xenoblade Chronicles
and tales 11
just the amount of NPC dialogue that
goes on yeah say you can catch at that
you know in the back of your mind or
something you're just passing through
there's people in magar with the real
problems and they express them to each
other and you could get the catch that
as you're walking around not to cut you
especially when you walk like right
after the the bombing so to speak and
you walk through the crowd everyone
destroy it like you'll hear the voices
individually of what everyone's going
through as you pass by yeah yeah yeah no
is exactly and to tie that in it's time
to the syquest which I know it's
contention with some people some
likewise are hit or miss but what they
do really well in this world build and
to really get you into it and it feels
special when you're having kind of this
connecting side quests that just flesh
out the culture the diversity of every
area not just make R itself it's
fantastic role building and atop that
the dynamic soundtrack oh I talk about
straight know just the amount of remixes
and renditions whenever you're just
walking in an area and just smoothly cut
into when you're writing is nothing like
I ever played before what I love about
it too is like they used the soundtracks
a lot more loosely than they did in the
original one mm-hm
like almost every time like Tiffin
client having a moment like tifus theme
song plays plays yeah okay I gotta jump
into Hackensack that got me going to you
know I started getting to the point
where there were certain areas
I loved because of certain beats like
remember when you fight those babies
collapse collapse yeah remix like beats
like that one yeah Coliseum be right
before you go on Jan Tomasz anybody
waiting and now know that Knox right and
they obviously we know the classic you
know battle music if you don't have
fields for that you're not a hero every
every ball fight of epic goes wrong
who's your man educator yet who's your
man on this music because he is
outstanding
like he's ridiculous I gotta look up his
neck he forgot his name is Lee
Masaharu something that do gonna
continue we do yeah I wanted original
composers yes omatsu rearranged his
music Wow yeah okay okay yes so it was
it was a mix of people that were
actually working on this soundtrack and
collaborating to see what's good you
know what they want to go with yeah
something like that yeah yeah I keep
missing his name but the 13 folks with
the with the 13 music that came up to me
when yes and in the collapse highway
it's so 13 I like that music but it's
interesting to compare those to me to
the old ones from Final Fantasy 7 okay
yes I'm glad you say that because
finally 13 regardless of what people
think about it as music oh my favorite
battle theme yes that's where you draw a
line bona fide news 13 I'm not saying
it's a great game but when it comes to
that battle theme yeah couldn't even
save that game but I know we get there
but he just so widely became can we
establish one big no and I'm not to say
some cars before even though it's not my
turn I'm still cutting into actor sir
whoo all right that's oh yeah and they
say his name my favorite part is when
they added to Axl didn't the after
children one when ages they added to
actual funny is when you fought so far
off at the end yeah he did a Kingdom
Hearts move in it yeah he does sins it
is the most scary terrifying initial
start of the song right like he's here
right and then obviously it crushed the
crescendo it builds up it goes to edit
go through all these motions now attic
educated me I believe obviously this is
something from
Advent Children I mean it's like a remix
- tell you help me our bar is there's
something that they oh yeah that's the
one yeah that's a that's the having
children okay fortunately they read they
remit actually they remix everything
they mix everything together with watch
as parts of a version that's what he's
floating in mid-air and he's a
singularity that is sucking in like a
black hole is that what the that's what
yes we talk about that way every beat in
the chanting and all that stuff but no
it's great hey it's great music and it
absolutely is know that continue that I
saw you bring it feels it's not saying
they like the music of remake is just a
history I motion spot for old fans and
just brings the height for new fans I
believe so it that's like one of my key
takeaways for me and just there's so
many other stuff but all the other
people speak so they can get their get
their taken you know what I love that
they did with the music because every
one of these bosses like Genova
Sephiroth they have different versions
of the of the of the music and they
switch to the more hardcore version the
deeper the fight you get into it so like
you'll be almost dead and that musics
like dude I think the music's harder
than it was one of those days adequate
you know how you fight a child
especially in Genova fight yeah when you
find a challenge right it's one of the
few times where I don't get mad when I'm
losing as much because I'm knocking to
the beat it's just a weird thing but
let's get let's get home get man hold
you don't ya know I got a lot of
positives I mean you north to worry
about me on this no no as a matter of
fact you know when we get later on in
this podcast one of the reasons that I'm
gonna be so strong on the rest is how
much I love this game
i as I said Final Fantasy 7 is important
to me and to some extent with modern
square-enix I haven't been it's not that
I haven't liked their output let's say I
haven't been fully satisfied with their
output in 15 years that their games have
something to say for them but there's
always something a little bit wrong and
I'm gonna see 15 was held together with
baling wire and scotch tape and I still
enjoyed myself but this is by far their
most holistically correct final fantasy
esque
magic game since maybe nine in my
opinion I know a lot of people like 10
that one wasn't for me but 9 is the last
time I can think of being really in love
with Final Fantasy and this one captured
that held it for about 34 and a half
hours out of 35mm and what I really
really loved about it is that I'm ok
with changes you're gonna hear a lot
from me later on I'm okay with changes I
like chapter 4 I like going and seeing
the top of the plate and seeing Jesse's
family I like what they add into these
kinds of things that are in the spirit
of the plot that they had put together I
actually really liked the battle system
I'm the kind of guy that says I love
turn-based battles I wish they were more
prevalent but I've got my known as I've
got my octopus travelers I can still
enjoy those elsewhere and Final Fantasy
has always changed its battle system
every single game
I adore Final Fantasy 13 s battle system
I'm okay with Final Fantasy 15 I have
you know no specific love for the ATB
systems from four through nine in any
given kind of combination I hate eight I
mean we can say that right up front but
that's one thing I'm sorry I said I
didn't mind we did my neighbor Barney's
with you already says he didn't like 80
the continued hold no I didn't like it
in any event I really like this battle
system I think that they found this kind
of perfect collision of we want to be
flashy we want to have action we think
that's necessary to get audience so good
and we want to add a DB to it and have
you think about things and what I really
liked is somebody mentioned that it felt
like a fighting game halfway through yes
and I started going back too hard and
you're getting in the front was like oh
I'm whizzing around now it's like we're
kind of clunky doing all this and it's
like okay I can I can see the flash and
I'm no I'm gonna hit X twice and hit you
with a braver yeah and you know it's all
this stuff and it really works out well
and I actually unlike me when playing
games halfway through playing Hillhouse
whatever it was I remember actually yes
you know what's crazy is the fact that
um I it's so good that the the fighting
system yeah I'm like this is their
fighting system don't change this like
he's been fine had one negative while
talking about I said I was sitting there
saying they've cracked the code I was
sitting there playing this game saying
if they finish this thing off we'll get
there then then this is gonna be one of
the biggest most important greatest
moves projects in video gaming history
and I'm there for 30 years of buying
Quint ologies of you doing four and six
and eight and nine
you can have my revenue until I die
square and then what a different
direction we'll get there but I really
really loved it and the all you know I
love the music I I sat on the Crystal
theme when it started up and night on
Friday last i sat there for ten minutes
yeah I loved horns I loved the drums I
loved it did to it so good and yeah I
really don't have anything that I really
disliked about the first thirty four and
a half hours of the game there's little
stuff we'll get into with- yeah look
like this mmm but overall I loved what
they did with their High Definition
towns that they said they could never
ever do again after not in or ten and I
really really loved it
and so that's where I come out at it
it's like something like everywhere
until you are escaping Midgar where the
normal game ends yeah is something like
a 15 out of 10 to me yeah I think I
think the reason this game was possible
is because they made 15 I think 15 put a
lot of the variables that they were
unsure of into place oh I thought you
were gonna say because they ditched the
Luminess 15 taught them that they just
go with unreal for God's sakes
pretty much yeah which is which is
garbage for 15 mm-hmm so I put on 15
after I played rebake it's like oh yeah
you could just feel it's it's being held
together it's trying engine back they're
taking it's like oh my god that's square
enix this is the square enix that is at
the top of their class and look at all
the shiny lights and oh did it freak
just do that and square-enix from old
positives of this remake man what did
you think they just nailed and they did
well uh to be honest with you there's
very few things I don't think they did
well obviously you know there's
the indie we'll get to that they you
know I feel like they did this summon
system you know okay I would prefer it
to be different I like how they made
where every weapon is relevant you can
easy weapon you want in the game you
just got a level it up yeah I like how
you know they branched every kit every
weapon with special abilities I like the
new way they did the magic system where
you get to scroll over mm-hmm you know
for the most part you know I there's
very few things that I sat here and I
tried to think of things that I did not
like and it's very very far between
mmm finish one but we'll get let me jump
a bit look this is I said this before
and I'll pee and because for our fantasy
7 means so much to me you know when I
heard the initial announcement of the
remake you're happy but there's part of
me Jay Bari that's like you can't mess
with the Mona Lisa right
don't touch the book like there's a
little fear a trepidation right cuz it's
like you know you don't want them to
ruin your a baby round we know how Hoke
feels we get to but you know for me I'm
always going to come in with a I don't
see a negative mindset but a mindset of
I'm gonna be very hard on you because
you're in my opinion messing around with
what I could sit a near perfection right
so as I get into the remake and we start
in there and I've seen a demo when a
demo came out really relieve my fears
right I'm like oh okay the Midgar you
know the bombing run you know it was it
was a completely expounded upon given a
great cinematic feel and then act wasn't
like bad like there's so much context
added like I'm like are we terrorists
like what do we do what kind of thing so
we're always terrorists yeah I just I
never captured that from the original
one they didn't like you know besides
like a little bit of fire like you
didn't go up buildings and up ladders
and see people cry felt away and they
like like Hector makes a good point one
thing I love about this game is that
when you
get characters in your party the game
switches a lot it makes you it forces
you to have one-on-one relationships
with people or certain groups and so on
and so forth and as you're with them and
going through these areas usually from
one area to the next it's like a path
you have to go what I ended up realizing
is that natural banter was great
character ability I'm thinking about
like what you said when arias and cloud
even I'm saying even you know Tifa stuff
like certain things I just thought was
was just so well and for me again I'm a
purist I'm old-school I'm sure my age
too though like I come from every are
turn-based that's it I'm really not with
heck and you know what you call it attic
with the new wave battle and precedent I
usually like that turn-based traditional
so it was a tough decision
you haven't booting up the game to even
do it cuz I'm like nah she played the
only but then part of me said look let
me just give it a chance right this is
one of my favorite games of all time let
me give it a chance with this new system
and let me tell you man this battle
system like BG said it best you skew
stock clunking around in the beginning
right you clunk around but as you get
going and you start getting familiar
Ally and you start learning that stagger
system and you start incorporating Limit
Breaks and summons and switch in on the
fly barri you start feeling like it's a
fighting game and it's on right and and
the thing that they do well and I'm not
a dog sauce guy be the first guy to
admit it right I'm really not a dog
sauce guy but I one thing I appreciate
about it is that the sense of
accomplishment when you beat something
difficult where I think their battle
system Trump's it it's just my opinion
I'm saying some controversial is that
they got this anime cinematic feel
during stages of the fight so during the
stage you not only do you see the bosses
change up and do whatever sometimes
you'll see commentary you see cloud and
Baron I'm talking about system I'm
what's going on like it's such a anime
you know cartoon-esque boombastic thing
that i love it i just wish wargames
would incorporate that because
especially like when you're fighting the
Turks like Reno and them guys it's
alright
it almost reminds me of old home like
70s kung-fu flicks I can you know one of
you knows it we got it we go get into it
they're like
it's such over the tailgate you took it
you know one of the most memorable
fights and act termed it was to me is
when you right before you fought you go
and you get on that bike yeah it was
that robot and when you did enough
damage to him you know Mortimer yeah
when you did enough damage to him he was
stuck at the back and the fire stopped
you from going left or right and he have
one be Mecca kill you yes side-quests
again hit a miss but there was some
memorable ones that like some people are
just absolutely reliable about the
bandits underneath the highway those are
those who stand out oh you know a happy
boy who's the little dude dad when
they're waiting for you at Aaron's house
Tom berry Tom berry in here I know we
did that with the fat chocobo buddy know
he was going to actually come they did
dad that was like very lure you know
they're like a lot of Lord because like
the average person who doesn't you know
doesn't know about them these are one of
the things in the Final Fantasy
franchise that could one hit you and
what's funny is like when that fight
started out okay this is gonna be a
magic kind of fight okay yes bro it's
it's little I'll be even characters like
Johnny and like walk wards ignore
guarded what is it war what's that Oh
market is hilarious like there's a
certain things that are goofy but it's
so well done that you just got to laugh
it just has the front face every bit has
these moments that I'm like well now are
we gonna get to the decadence the last
thing I would say is the materia system
I do like that you know everything is
thought it is they make some subtle
changes but I actually like I don't
addict may disagree but I actually like
that you have to earn the summit I don't
I mean even though in to be old Final
Fantasy 7 we can kind of you know use
Leviathan use it for you and at will
right
I kind of it adds to the epicness like
so when you earn it you finally built up
that bar it's like oh you gonna get this
work because y'all put me
a lot of you know a lot of yo damages
stuff so that's how I feel about do I
they pretty much hit you with like FF 10
and 12 like you know what the expert is
you gotta you know defeat them to get
them yeah well you can't you can you can
find some of them in the world too so
that's still there yeah I got some
positive hold of Jabbar real quick I
remember you actually mention this like
we gotta mention that that second you
know nostalgia egg they gave us when you
fought that behemoth in the basement
yeah oh yeah oh it's height:0 yeah yeah
and when you kill when you get like when
you killed it I knew it did mediate and
I sit down alive waiting for and it's
just stop sitting in it like stands up
or like yeah I'm gonna go over here I
know we got a couple more passes before
we go to negative so oh yeah oh yeah I'm
just gonna say like I like the UH you
know that they didn't make every weapon
useless you know that I typically oh you
know okay you get a new weapon the other
one the last one is trash tell anything
yes but now each one of them you know
has this ability you got to get the
proficiency in is that you know and then
you that adds to your collective of
different moves and each one of your
characters you know let that's eat that
and all of them are useful depending on
I you know there's the truth the
situation that veteran shout out to that
stance with that auto stance that
counters that save me a lot oh it's like
the best movie bro shut up the attic
foretell see I didn't know that when you
switch to the weapon and once you have
the proficiency that it stays with you
just despite any other weapon change
Jewish I'm the attic Lemieux continued
yeah and like with the materia system I
don't know if anybody if anybody else
felt this way I feel like you've maxed
out like materia really fast even though
a weapon proficiency - oh yeah yeah yeah
that I got that into my my second um
please sleep wrong know what's funny
yeah I was about to say I got that after
I beat the game yeah this one's going to
watch take a minute but yeah like trust
me I was grinding before I beat the game
I grind
a lot of AP the max out decent material
yeah because when you beat the game you
get trip away I didn't know like hard
mode was doing all of that but I still
wanted that grind after Maxo because I
wanted to do the channeling mission so I
can get to so let me just ask a quick
quick quick question because do you
think because they let you play hard
more and have triple-a P triple XP
they're gonna let you take all this [ __ ]
to the next game because I don't think
they're going to good question I don't
think it I don't know I was questioning
that I'm like we're doing all of this in
this first game yeah I can't see how
they would let you take everything maxed
out to the next game that's a good point
trying to figure it out I don't know how
they're fine I think I think they're
just going to have default materia and
like have like certain all of them
certain levels I don't think they're all
gonna be like base and level right but I
don't think they're gonna let us take
this Opie [ __ ] we got now do you think
carried over no I think you're just
gonna have a load out I mean I think
what max is 50 on this one so I think
you probably start in 2 and if you do
decide to start Game two to you 5 it
would be my guess level 25 with some
base stuff and then just you know this
isn't Mass Effect this is good enough
and I want you to have an enjoyable
experience anyway continually do you
finish it up your positives and stuff
yes pretty much I just love the weapons
and upgrades and everything like that
and you know the Chadli and the battle
Intel and you know small things like me
you don't have to stop and engage with
every like NPC in the world to hear what
they're saying it's just you know it's
like conversations you hear out there
out loud I'm like ass
so imagine if you have to stop and talk
to each for all time
now that would have made this game at
least like five hours on wait a minute
I love that that natural hearing the
audio terms of passing by towns folk and
getting their story yeah I love that
small stuff like that being I do love
that too yeah like being able to
multi-use items you know quickly you
know like yeah just they thought a lot
of the small things
and I last thing I'll say it before more
home set pieces
I thought the Shinra building looked
immaculate like there's certain pieces
that certain air even you know when you
go in some of the sectors and you look
up and you see that skybox Hector right
and you see that the plate is gone and
it's just certain aspects of it vision I
know it's we talk about some individual
inconsistencies here and there but it's
a beautiful game like I mean when you
when you even like the faces you know it
is spectacular the eyes everything about
and just a seamless switching from
cinematic to gameplay is just manner it
was something else but that's what I
gotta lotta new thing else and then
we'll get into yeah as far as positive
um like I said I've been saying this on
Twitter but let's go this is by far like
one of the best games where this comes
today boss battles all like every boss
battle has been like fun yeah dynamic
and if never that oh this is a this is a
boring boss fight everything that felt
really good to do man the music hates
you know what I mean that you know on
Twitter that you see the guy sitting
back yeah and then he fits for like okay
you know me my yonus this game has the
best boss battles in any file fancy I
would have to agree yo it the way how
they did the boss battles like turning
regular enemies into like bosses like
you have secret enemies at eligor and is
it to a boss fight this is this is
amazing man the battle system oh oh oh
you know can I can I get cocky for a
second you know when the first trailer
dropped you know PSX you know I
definitely put out there that this is
gonna be a hybrid type battle system you
know it's gonna be action
slash turn bass you know a lot of people
with bashing me like these talking about
Jaguar II do you even play okay all
right
that all of this hybrid badasses to now
let's go back you know 9 months 10
months ok but yeah I guess I been to I
will be streaming about the game for
like about 10 months if you guys want to
follow it go ahead and watch that
it's cool um yeah the material like you
guys said I love that you can still have
your material bills I like the fact that
they didn't really change the material
that much with it you do earn it pretty
quickly at far as leveling up I do agree
with that but some of them it does take
long yeah and I do I do like the pacing
of the game you know like chapter the
chapter the pacing is very very like
upbeat even though you have slow moments
but you're still doing stuff I know a
lot of people struggle by the decided
missions a hit or miss yeah but to me
the side missions are way too important
to be skipping or hit you as far as in
points like I want all the items that's
gonna beef me beneficial because I'm
telling you when you play on hard mode
you gonna want to do them side mrs. Alba
have to go get my Mughal medals and have
to go see the kids
oh yeah transcripts online you gotta
give credit to the mini-games okay the
minigames a whack a box but scroll B G
let's go just know my joy is up there
man me I'm a Coliseum do but could tell
you what your darts no it's not [ __ ]
if not stick I don't want to hear what
if your darts is not at six I don't want
to hear knaves no Jews no Jews got me I
can't I can't get Julie I'm gonna be
hard more than i'ma come back to judo
let me come back to jewel market
obviously one of the highlights of the
game but cross-dressing seed bro hello
there what is it what's the name of the
club no honey oh honey you have to
hilarious standout moments in it besides
declasse I didn't even think they were
gonna go attempted on whatever his name
is
see
I knew they were gonna do it but the
funny thing to me was the things around
it cuz I didn't know about your man that
was definitely iron cloud during the
battle you know say it goes yeah I even
know about you man so that's funny right
but to me no side no and I put this
little Twitter
it's a funniest thing at that time to me
is before that no one who the teacher
the kids was and then go and see in high
in the back alley and the honey blame
and I'm like Miss thing I know you don't
do this when the sides like that Club
don't talk to me cup talk about my
favorite my favorite scene is madam and
one of my favorite characters game yo
madam and she did Mike man cloud right
man oh yeah that was the equivalent of
like going to the club which it was your
group and then want to eat one of your
boys just can't force onto the state
goal is what Ryan he got to a boy he was
banned natural with it no he was bad
that wrong with it look at Matt
uncomfortableness still moving though
yeah Oh what did you think about the the
whole wall barky that in general and you
know the dawn and all that stuff did any
that stuff resonate with you yeah I like
ball market you know him to me I I think
it went a little long so I don't think a
lot of the places were pays to be okay
but wall market was a big chunk of time
chapter 9 is long gimme given a favorite
give me I'll favorite like chapters or
any set pieces that really resonated
with you well you know I I love the
bombing run from the star yes I played
the demo of over a year before it came
out in 97 and then yeah I think the
Shinra museum tour yeah and and and in
the video though the feeling it was a
maze good yes no there's a lot of little
tidbits don't know
you love how I got rid of all that
unnecessary stuff in the original one
where you had to go find this guard key
to get this they still had that but it
was oh yeah yeah go to Midgar plates Pro
to open that little chest yes shout out
to hope shout out to them trolling did
you take that I took the steps and went
up all sixteen oh yeah it was it was a
horrible experience but it was pretty
fun did you do that I did not I did not
I remember that from the original I
didn't I didn't do it in this one
actually no yes what's funny is like
bear is struggling yo but that's a cloud
try to put off this bravado like this
when he starts struggling and that's
before red even calls him a sack of [ __ ]
another thing I love about the game is
that they did a really sense for this
game much as far as like characters no
not like a sensory stuff as far as like
how the characters was talking and you
know like you know how bear is always
cursing and yes stuff like that that
stuff wasn't really like censored I
really I really dig no I think that's it
I mean I really like Shinra headquarters
I was a little worried about is that's a
piece of the original game that I don't
love quite as much gotcha
and so I thought they did a really great
job with it I could have done with a
less teeth on chandeliers but I was
doing what I was doing that chandelier
part I was thinking myself the whole
time I was like this is unnecessary know
me that [ __ ] but would be impressed
there you go it's interesting right
because you've seen the entire game
cloud jump off a falling pipe 30 feet
into the air yeah yeah and you know
later just a couple couple minutes later
he's gonna be slicing through a train
anyway we'll get there but just have
that kind of beat a barrier we got to
come all the way across the chandeliers
I just thought what's funny what's funny
is like tifus super liked if his Limit
Breaks she goes that high look there's
somersault next to it you're all good
but no I really liked a lot of it and
yeah you know one of the things I've
seen online is some people don't like
the dungeons as much as others I
actually really really liked them I
remember going to underplate with the
lights like I really loved that and that
was that was new I think so had a great
time with all that stuff
no Depok epic movies how did you guys
feel about the the lack of being able to
farm efficiently in this game there were
two there was a to me it wasn't a
problem because there was a key spot
early to farm in a factory yeah in 93
yeah yeah what also when you're in the
in the slums right before you go on like
right before you actually go on the
mission with Jesse I think you could
actually arm in that little area right
there that's probably like the earliest
one you could actually farm so for me I
did it I did it a good amount there so I
wouldn't really have to do it much
further in the game that can also farm
yeah the part with when you're with the
highway the busted a highway or there's
a collapse I weighed out with my former
spot yes it's interesting because I
actually didn't farm it all and one of
the things that I thought they did a
really good job was keeping on the curve
for the most part hard challenging but
but mostly on the curve the battle
system is we talked about is great one
of the things that maybe it's a little
harsher on than even original kind of
Final Fantasies is that if you lose a
person you can get out outside that
spiral real quick
yeah and that can't happen and what's
really interesting about that is that
you can get absolutely just destroyed by
someone and if you're paying more
attention to the health bars and
everything else you can then in turn
destroy them yeah and that's a really
cool thing of that battle system that
doesn't usually happen in a Final
Fantasy where it's just like okay I need
my attack needs to be plus three because
I'm just not doing enough I don't enough
yeah and hard a little bit when people
healings very frustrating but you know
that's how I feel with Buried IV oh my
synergies gone because Barrett that's my
support what I want to do I want to
touch on the negatives but I want to do
it what it's
negatives - endings will save anything
for last right
so figure that from your tab eggie I
would hope so what we want to do is what
did we dislike about the game no ending
talk don't know anything - anybody could
jump in I got a few uh as far as like
even though I enjoyed woolmarket yeah I
still preferred how the original way did
it as far as like you got to go from
section to section to get the different
pieces to fill up your house yes yes
yeah um I just felt like they just kind
of just gave it to you I mean you did
other things inside missions as far as
it leading up to what title address you
get which is cool but I just still like
the original way better with that um
like party all night was like that right
I mean like her party all day or
whatever the heck that side quest was
called was yes yeah you kind of like
walking around a wall market mm-hmm
saying yeah um the textures I know a lot
of yous gonna bring the texture there's
definitely one thing at first it did
kind of bother me because like you know
you when you first boot up the gaming
you're taking all these screenshots
about oh look at the background it's
great so like you look like a ps1 game
you know the meat kind of do you of well
you know later on I just kind of like
eyes whatever it is cause my BG said
majority game just look good yeah um
another thing that bothered me these are
small gripes and I already have so many
dislikes but these are my small gripes
here at it um the saving me but I feel
like when I want to save it should be
instantaneous like boom the way they
take the load let's look it up it was
like and then you put a shortcut and
it's still loaded I'm like me a little
bit I know that's small it might be
little - I'm with you on that yeah big
time I would panic say before certain
things yeah it could be a little quick
outside and pf5 please another thing I
dislike was um the proximity on voice
thing where like even if you're close to
somebody you're having that little
banter which I like the banter but right
if you're looking if you're very right
where your characters
to the left like the volume will go go
off yeah you know I mean and it's like
oh I gotta turn I got a turn to
character I go bad that were happy
without one far too far ahead
and they're saying important things and
I can't unison yeah you just see that
you see the text but he see what X yeah
good to see I was gonna design the
voices I thought you were gonna say
because we put it in the positives that
we like the the town banter I love it
too one they repeat if you walk by them
too much there should be like a trigger
but two there they have these mobs and I
remember looking at one of the TV
screens and the slums they have these
mobs that are right next to you and they
will talk during the cinematics like
where's the post paying attention to oh
yeah yeah and it's just so it's just so
modern square UNIX really which is like
oh really good idea but it's slightly
off yeah you know for the most part did
not bill when you look for like the
music to like um like you you listen to
hear the music but if you're not like
pointed to that vicinity where the
music's coming from you won't right
ladies firstly with the discs right the
discs yeah yeah but as far as Nick
that's like my real negatives with the
game would you man what what what
negatives would she did like in no no
ending part but just as far as the game
itself yeah sure so uh one of the things
that I noticed from the get-go was some
of the innovations on the NBC faces were
just really like stone and it had to be
off for a little bit but actually what I
was watching maximally news stream last
night saying that in the one the behind
the scenes of family 7 remake that
lip-syncing that they do in the game is
an AI it's not really yeah it's not
actually man-made as they go on they go
through the game to fix it up but it's
actually an algorithm where the voice of
the care of the actor is do it AI is
actually matched in game so which is
super impressive it's like genius level
stuff to like it saves so much time but
I didn't notice a couple of times where
was a little off and it kind of it kind
of threw me off my immersive experience
but other than that uh there's not
really a lot that I really didn't like
but I would say that a couple chapters
do go on for quite a bit longer yeah so
some did drag
some respect yeah especially chapter 17
that was one it's like a three for our
chapter which was 17 to the lab right
yes I love that chapter them I like to
chapter but I'm weird heck in the sense
that like I love the concept of the
splitting up right exactly yeah I love
the communication calm and you know I
get it it did felt like it it went on
maybe 30 for 30 minutes maybe more did
it need it too
I could I could have been cut thirty
minutes out but I did like the concept I
just thought it went on a big long no
there's just me but other than that
isn't that big could do you know yeah
other scene was threatened I can see
where it's gonna work the the pacing
sometimes it gets a little slow but
that's where like the moments when you
stop after the crazy set pieces you just
went through the conscious get into the
world of it yeah you do notice it it
stops every now and then but yeah for me
it was good but yeah it's there's a
couple times where you're still to a
crawl and I was like okay let's pick it
up a little bit yeah but yeah no no it's
not really much that I kind of like
didn't like about the game other than
just a very minor nitpick stuff like the
air combat yeah oh yeah I feel you feel
the way about that yeah I feel could be
a little better I mean you're the answer
to it all magic right you could we
should still be able to hit in the air
consistently exactly this is an S word I
think though you were Kingdom Hearts to
it could take a page from Kingdom Hearts
to where you when you're in the air you
have a continuous string of air combos
so that you're not constantly dropping
to the ground and going nothing else
thing with Hector the arm of the day I
was like yeah I agree with him with
certain parts but there's weapons that
when you level it up it helps with air
common especially with T flash you need
a certain one to defy someone in the air
sure I get you I get you what like
what's funny is that the most difficult
people for me to fight were the people
in the air because like that the first
thought they'd go to an area no The
Dresden magic the drakes didn't give me
issues it was the people on the
propellers like
I'll wait for them just wait for McLeod
and Calipari them they stagger it got to
the point cuz I was trying to be like
endurance with like this the magic but
if I saw them I'm like I'll poppin ether
here how old this lightning boy I think
the air combat is part of this but one
of the things I would say is kind of my
light negatives is there are scenarios
in which you can just be rigged wrongly
in material
oh yeah I don't have any of their yes
correct where you're fighting the guy
you know I remember in maybe it was the
collapsed highway you've got the
spinning blade guys that are just
untouchable by your melee folks oh and
if you don't have the ATP and you're
just not quite rigged correctly for
magic you just wind up essentially
running around and waiting for your ATP
to fill yes and your dad go out yeah
that's where that's why you gotta master
that parry with cloud because when they
come at you and you parry them that
counter hit it staggers them like 80%
bar and you don't yeah that happened to
me hope that happened to me in Hell
House I didn't have when I was what the
hell I didn't tell you anything when his
windows went to the opposite element yes
I never had wind like I never had enough
wind yeah you know with my longest boy
house terrorized me but right there was
a there was a couple bosses in the game
that are that are really there's one
that I really enjoyed how they did it
was the dude that you were climbing the
Midgard Shenron mansion the that the
headquarters
you fought you know it was the the one
that you fought on on the side you have
like three different floors of a fight
in one tile
it was to do with the propellers they
did that chase you through the whole
climb though I like how they did his
flight part of me doesn't like how they
did the the machine at the end cuz in
the original you fought him on a
helicopter on an elevator oh yeah and
you're in the lobby yeah yeah yeah
pardon me felt like it should have been
on the elevator but I get it that would
have been a hard fight to do technically
but it's just like that was I remember
that
because in the original fight you know
you you fought him they're going down
wide Tifa and cloud where they only
cloud fought him cloud fought him on the
roof and I I didn't really like condemn
it because it wasn't on the elevator but
I was like I felt like you should have
been on the elevator okay yeah I was
definitely expecting that elevator scene
to be in there but I was like okay you
just gonna do in a lobby but the fight
ended up being good anyway so what I
understood why they didn't have an
elevator because that would have been a
rough fight to to program for to fight
in the elevator with two small spaces
battling that makes more sense to have
your guy jump up and slice something in
a different elevator and it's different
when it's in a real-time so it didn't
bug me I actually like that that me
growing into that fight shows them kind
of aligned next to each other and the
elevator and it's like I know we're not
gonna do that we're just gonna slam into
the ground how'd you guys how'd you guys
feel about the Roofus not even
necessarily the fight it was like when I
rang you're fighting tomorrow it's magic
and it's counter stance a lot no you
have to be hiring them yeah yes it's a
defensive fight it's a defensive fight
it's magic it's a lot of counters a lot
of pairing but but like even like with
the meta I'm like okay let's be real
Rufus was not even like a memorable boss
fight in the first right there's another
dude yes why is he she with guns no he
was nice what's funny is another thing
you didn't understand is like he's
linked to his dog and if you unlike him
from his dog he goes you got it lately
unconscious if you if you if you use the
thrust move yeah it will unlike him from
his dog and you can fight the dog by
himself for a couple
so please I know these weeks of breath
think Rufus himself is weak too braver I
think that's like clouds like how I beat
him is I would pair him and if I didn't
Perry when I went in for the the reload
I hit him twice to the after the reload
and then I would switch to the triple
slash right but reload that's where you
got a tracking problem where's bosses
that are like you know like oh you can't
you can't touch me like it's just the oh
you mean until this like very the second
he just shows up behind you hits you
look if you look at a roof with fight
it's pretty much like an upgraded Reno
fight because Reno is kind of same thing
where you're dodging you got a
counter-attack but roof is just like
100% now at least Reno you can actually
hit him roof is this automatic counter
if you don't hit him at the right time
and once again it's just I just didn't
expect that I feel like it's very
jarring from what he was in the first
fight I'm like why is he
Itachi with guns where did this one
thing one thing I didn't remember and
you guys can uh correct me or not
remember when you fought Rufus and uh
you fought Rufus Reno and and what's the
other dudes night rude rude you fought
them both on top that tower did you
fight them both on top that tower in the
original one for some reason I want to
say you just fought Reno oh yeah you bet
for Reno I think it was a Reno Reno ran
his ass head but the next time the next
time you fight you fight rude in that
little in that little cave after the the
midgar's Solem yeah that's why you fight
rude at but it was you go ahead my pen
wait you start fighting all the all the
turks together i found you know andrew
fight easier than just the the rude
fight the room fight like that was the
real fight he got him yeah yeah rue was
very disrespectful I remember he put ass
that sleep go to sleep yeah the track at
one time I had Reno putting one person
in a pyramid and rude putting the other
person to sleep yeah
it was wroth bandit helicopters going on
there are certain battles I'm like come
on fan y'all being real extra this is a
bit much you're very far she was fun oh
yeah you know I stopped you from doing
anything yet I agree
now what it I wouldn't touch my big
negative that's not anything that story
related and I want to I wanna know how I
feel about this cuz I feel this was a
missed opportunity i'ma bring discussion
that to Hank as well too we get to you
know we in Shinra mansion at the tower
we do you know we working our way up to
the top you get to general over ding you
see the trail you know I mean we've been
looking for the president know all that
and you know the sheriff comes through
and the thing that bothered me that I
thought was a missed opportunity and I
know why they feel I don't why they did
it but I thought cuz I'm an addict beat
this game bar you probably beat this
game all you guys beat this game before
me right and hope so I'm thinking what
is this shock thing that everyone's
talking about right all so I'm thinking
I'm at the end right you know the funny
thing is that's the I beat this in two
days I played it Friday and I beat it
Sunday
yeah and I remember the whole time he
playing that I was tired I was like four
or five in the morning I just got off
work in 12 hours I was like I got to see
what Dreamcast guys talking about the
year I got see but it would literally
motivate me to keep playing cool and I
had to do it so it's like I get to that
point and then the game decides oh this
is crazy
this is bold I was like I'm upset I saw
ill-ass like BG played he was like hey
that's the news I was phone goes a white
guy that was that was good I thought
that was the boss on those fake
emotional way that reckful II wasn't a
moment go right I mean like the read
conversation is right before that
where he says what the ghosts are yes oh
they're trying what they need to
establish to go into the ending and I'm
not but is that this is what these
ghosts do this is what they're capable
of right and so I'm gonna frickin revive
Barret and if I would have put something
in the negative column throughout once
you get to the end and this isn't
directly anything adjacent but you go
for all the protection if you want good
is there are so many scenes now I'm kind
of trying to go back through it enjoy
the things that I enjoyed yeah there are
so many things now in this remake
quote-unquote that have the scenes from
the original that are gonna go a
different direction that are going a
different weird way that are then
intervening with these go yes that's the
ending one of the things I tweed that
was at the ending goes backwards in time
to take away some of the fun that you
enjoyed before it and I mean it's almost
means yes these goat scenes exist and
they are actually intervening in what
you know from the final fantasy subject
almost felt like a narrative they felt
like a narrative troll like like we know
what's supposed to happen we know you
know what's supposed to happen right but
we're here to envy and do it like
whenever anyone thats what a whole
destiny thing is coming in yes you know
you know what's funny
I have so many people that I've been
watching the reaction and they were
referring to the the whispers as the
original Final Fantasy 7 thing up here
in the house we'll talk about that
though we have another tab I'm wait okay
the game yes I'm sorry I wanted anybody
it for the rest of the game it it has
those scenes so you've got we win we
beat Reno we beat Roode we're about to
stop the pillar and they just don't let
you it's a story completely and that can
be okay we'll talk about that but it
really does fundamentally change that
was that's happening that was the only
time I wasn't I wasn't about because
almost every other time the whisper
showed up something happened that
prevented the stories from going forward
and I'm out there yeah I've
personally feel like Sephiroth from avid
children somehow went back into
Sephiroth from the passes law t because
he shows up in times at the beginning of
the game that he was never there right
and it's like he's trying to antagonize
clout to try to piss off the whispers
and i feel like the only way the
whispers would show cuz if you read
their BIOS the whispers only show up
it's time is starting to be destroyed to
the assessment area giving you more
story in context and in the actual game
I know ya know who the whispers are or
have a theory or break it down baby yeah
Barrett from the future from from our
past that's what it felt like I feel
like the whisper this might there
whispers is definitely you know the
cetera and they dare to because they
dare to protect the planet actually said
to stop the you know I I feel like I is
I believe that do because Aerith can the
air earth can talk to them for some yes
emember right girl you remember what air
who did with Marlene when she's chata
Marlene was like oh so you're one of the
as you like did I make something up in
my head when Marlene and Aerith did the
hug it almost felt like there was some
type of connection that she felt in
Marlene yeah God miss read that like it
felt like there's a living for paws
inside was she went to go rescue her
from the bomb I like she had they shared
an ability and they realized it during
the hug maybe I'm looking too much into
it I think Marlene were recognizes it in
Aerith and I think that's the same thing
that Aerith does to read so you've got
Aerith being a kind of wild card yes and
and and one of the other negatives that
I would say is and and maybe you know I
had been children all this other stuff
we'll get there I know me go but that
you know what in the God's green earth
is Sephiroth doing in this game yeah and
when you get to the ending when you get
to the ending and you have that fight
and we'll talk about that and it's still
one of the problems one of the big
negatives I have not about the content
of the ending but what happens at the
end isn't what why aren't we all
fighting him where is that information
coming Aerith gives a speech which
doesn't make a ton of sense for what her
knowledge base doesn't it
I like it says but it's like she has the
knowledge she's being vague she faint
but to be honest I got more context
what's going on with everything's red
red is like when Gabe is Iike me like
whenever is called him like suddenly
like evaluated like red him like there I
know who you are like you're a terrible
person at all that you not yeah because
because what's funny is she says pretty
much everything's pretty much saying
that Genova is a real cause that's not
really set from there remember in in in
Crisis Core way you know I appreciated I
played all this Laura Final Fantasy
Sephiroth has genovia's head he has a
component in over race manipulation over
to do all of that to get other pieces of
Genoa with like the body the specimen
ray he's carrying at the end and all
that stuff so that's not really suffer
over there that's destined over but
that's should I should always use to
manipulate like how do I be manipulated
it's the same way how they do yes like
saffron he's pretty much he pretty much
is in the live stream you know and
crater and he knows is low-key Sephiroth
is low-key Genova son like not
technically but she was born he was born
and raised with her cells in question I
don't think I don't think she I think
she's manipulating him I don't think
it's the other way around
no I would disagree I guess we're on the
next tab we're almost there what I would
say is that Sephiroth is definitely at
the end clearly the one I think those in
around him is that he wants to stop the
whispers he wants you to kill destiny
right and he apparently needs the party
to do it okay
he's he's going there's no sense which
makes no sense I don't disagree on any
of that being
separately you to kill the whispers
makes no sense it's like why did he need
you to kill the harberger when he could
have easily have done that himself well
you know why does he need the party is a
great question but I think it's clear
that he want so you talk about a time
traveler and I think maybe what
something along those lines because he
clearly is like oh that original Final
Fantasy seven didn't go my direction
we're gonna have to go a different or
you're gonna have to go a different way
hey cloud wouldn't it be cool if you
killed these ghosts now what I don't
understand is you know that the flat
they get before the ending I considered
before the portal before the ending
cause I'm already switched I already
hear weird it is that when you get to
that point you know why does the party
jump on for killing destiny because you
know yes humanity may or may not be
destroyed depending on how you do this
without Advent Children everything else
but why did they suddenly go oh crap we
can't have that future i think mostly
one I mean I think that was traumatic I
think that the the way that they try and
explain it in a really bad terms is that
speech at earth did where she was like
look you do win you the the planet
suffers I die pretty much but you do win
she can't be stopped he's literally
making portals out of the whispers we
can't stop him we have to stop him so I
think that was what they tried to do
like and for some reason they gave Baird
that like shy before he went the port I
don't know what that was about like out
of everyone that could've gave that
shine - they gave it to Barret hmm where
he was like pretty much they pretty much
gave you we choose our own destiny
resonate it does being preconceived for
us you know yeah you're getting little
tidbits here and there from like
defeating each Harbinger and all that
stuff showing you like here's some of
your future even if someone else looked
like the cookie I think err if it's not
confused with a book write something but
I think what's going on what's going on
yeah from like the cottage she's saying
especially if you go back to her
dialogue near the N or he over cefr
opens that portal she's hitting it hey
this guy is bad he's gonna do something
really really crazy we're the one once I
can stop him so we had to go in and
change anything to to just to as a step
to stop him and willin and fighting fate
for them when they got those images of
the future yeah then they saw that as
something bad like oh but maybe we
didn't win because that's you that earth
knows what he's going to do not what he
did in the previous games because the
way she was talking like if she knows
that the past knows what's going on she
knows that they win and heiress persona
really isn't the kind of like self right
like
so like she thought could be selfless
like she would literally go die again
just to summon only so the original Tom
Lane I feel like she knows that what
he's doing isn't that and there's
nothing they can do to stop him unless
they go with him okay let's take it do
it to do everything that Arif needs to
do Sephiroth is still gonna be
manipulating cloud to get what he wants
to get so you can you know do what he
got to do so that's why I think the
whole set off party's coming in like oh
we really got to stop him but it still
is just a trail like this is why this is
where I want you destiny is trying to
stop me from leading you to the trail
where I want you to get the black
materia guess I can summon media and all
that stuff that's why I need you to stop
what whispers from doing that what it is
is Sephiroth knows he's gonna lose it
he's defying destiny and he's making
them defy destiny to stop him oh please
playing he's playing a real a real
tricky card on them hold make it seem
like third they're gonna end up
something bad so I'm gonna make them my
that's what I don't understand that's
trying to manipulate the party yeah and
you at the party then saying what we
have to beat destiny and you've got air
at the talks to the live stream why why
I I can't get from A to C which is why
does the party want to defy destiny
right here when Sephiroth has there's
not enough build up they should have
more of a build up like reasons why
people want to do I agree they go
literally they go litter they go
literally from driving on that bite -
yeah let's all go in here we don't care
what's gonna happen personally I really
felt like the whispers wasn't me they
have you didn't even have them in it you
didn't need them in the game to be
honest with you you feel like that's the
problem - Jay they're overthinking their
own game I'm gonna be too much we're
sorry
I feel like that's the problem - is we
also have one game and we all have
different perceptions on what happened
in that game what that should not happen
they're very cryptic being encrypted for
a reason like I said like I said in the
beginning I feel like they doing this
because
they know the game is gonna be multiple
parts oh yeah we like yo you want to get
the rest like here you go certain things
that you have to answer in this one
like for instance why the whispers doing
what they're doing like I feel like you
at the bare minimum you have to explain
why sepharose acting different than he
did in the original a previous even a
lot of things even showing Zac scene you
know the mean where Oh everybody always
I want to just say one thing because
this is the baseline fundamental reason
why you see me go on tirade yes and why
this is so disappointing to me is that I
think we can all agree at this point
after the end of chapter 18 that what we
did not play was a remake of Final
Fantasy 7 that was a bait and switch oh
yeah yeah so that's the first point the
second to be honest with you hope like
what would this even be considered are
you sitter in an adaptation it's not I
don't even think it's a sequel what did
yeah I think I think is a power type
thing where you can have a time traveler
it's Back to the Future 2 in those
scenes in 1955 right it's Sephiroth is
back in time [ __ ] stuff up yes and
now we have to deal with that and the
Timecop ghosts have come out and said
stop doing that Sephiroth and and then
Sephiroth convinces the party to say we
don't need no Timecop ghosts you should
know time table ghost and also they're
gonna look like a Kingdom Hearts villain
that's ok it should be this complex I
mean I look at it as like it's it's a
remake on it on except this is on the
alternate timeline and it's like we're
like just like infinity war where
Daniels became very self-aware that he
lost yeah it's like ok so this is what I
gotta do to possibly win and I guess
that's what Sephiroth is doing I'm ok
with with the dilation of this part
being open endgame isn't a
remake of infinity war more the rest the
MCU saga
nor was it sold that one I don't mind I
don't mind actually you selling it to me
as something that is new
the sequel aside quo a sideways
Universal lost whatever you want to call
it what I mind is selling it to me as
remake teasing it seven years ago
teasing it thirteen years ago and now
five years ago
at last the freakin promise has been
made he's got damn liars all right we'll
hold hold hold I got to stop before is
the same thing oh yes I'm saying but let
me hold it yeah I'm with you my thing is
your beam your main point of contention
is to the letter of the law they did not
follow and recreate Final Fantasy so if
they would have done that you were good
that's all of you finish that if you
finish the end of chapter seven the end
of chapter 18 at the bike in the car
have beaten motor ball they're driving
away you get that shot from them leaving
Midgar you cut the credits right there I
think you've delivered on your promise
right what I what is what is bothersome
to me is I play all of that I love it I
enjoy it I say they cracked the code I
start thinking about Cosmo Canyon and
gold saucer and temple the ancients and
all this good stuff and then they get to
the end and they say did you like that
did you like what we did right there we
can do it modern square-enix can do it
through and you're not getting the
goddamn traveling monster people enjoy
okay so let the let the LAT what about
to the art of them give it to rush the
panel but I gotta ass hold it what about
to the argument that people will say you
already have Final Fantasy seven if you
worry you could play the original game
and be fine so why not let them take
this Liberty then why didn't you decide
to sell it as that Square Enix the
answer is million dollar billions of
dollars well yeah well yeah yeah that's
one thing that's one thing with this
remake is it's like all the compilation
of everything of Final Fantasy 7 they
have incorporated within this remake you
know it gives you hints of avalanche
trying to assassinate a president you
know they show
even show you from crisis call gas
complaining about chapter four or the
fact that avalanche is now part of a
bigger group and all this little stuff I
don't love kiri a but I don't complain
about talking about he doesn't like the
fact that they advertised this game for
years as a remake and he didn't mind
adaptations on something that was in the
core in you doesn't like the fact that
at the end they're like yo we gave you
thirty-five hours of greatness
now we go do what we want to do we know
what you want to do does that does that
now coming into now basically the eight
this the game ends it it says the
unknown journey hook so so they live it
like we are literally at a point where
this thing can go laugh they could
literally create a we have a multiple
timeline thing possibly going on we see
Zack I don't think it's a possible I
don't think it's gonna go left because
like I said that ball fight the the the
whisper and Harbinger is giving you the
future but I get my here's my point we
are supposed to be fighting like they're
doing yeah you killed him you killed him
he's not stopping in you know they're
doing classic Final Fantasy seven ending
callbacks when he is doing this and
you're doing like all this stuff I was
somebody we I did with Sephiroth came
out I was expecting a cutscene something
boombastic and then tune in next week
yeah whatever whatever and then I'm like
oh we fighting
oh we we're doing this okay the thing is
you you kill you killed a harbinger but
the whispers are still there I don't
know they're you know no the mystery is
dead that aura has an obtuse way of
telling stories but when they all turn
into golden showers and he showers all
the city yes then that's everybody's
saying destiny isn't that it was blowing
up the reason that Zack appears in front
of Midgar and it's covered in whispers
yes is because he's not allowed to go
there yeah that's not his story it was
die right now
and they all dissolved and then he's
Kari and cloud back home there's all
sorts of [ __ ] now and whatever you say
like it or not it's gonna be Kingdom
Hearts no kid Mars random I go for our
way home I'm not a kid oh [ __ ] what I
saw what the whispers was that this that
was kind of like their constraint of
going o to the story in different ways
right we got a pretty faithful remake
with Bowie guy here we did we did we
definitely did with woolmarket
with Shira they made some liberties
right maybe but they made some liberties
before when you destroy the whispers
that opens up all the possibilities when
it comes to telling story how they want
to go with it so we can meet Vincent
early on maybe you feet could has to be
mandatory so like it opens up a
possibilities of what story but yeah
we're basically fighting
Sephiroth almost in an ending stake
fashioned already does that take away
from an eventual final conclusion battle
again with I felt like I'm torn man
because I like the idea of doing
something different but again you're
messing with a lot of stuff II the
potential for this to go wrong is
trouble
you know and that and I agree with you I
definitely agree with you on that and
that's why when I finished first
finished the game I was lukewarm because
look at square next past record right
for releasing games and even with the
597 compilation story I think it's been
messy it hasn't been all that good so
that potential for it to fail is really
high just like this remake right we're
so skeptic going into it whether they
can create something amazing at the end
of it remains yet to be seen we have to
see how parties in the shape-up and how
they're gonna take the story in
different directions so I'm optimistic
about it yeah how cautious as the 557
fan that love this the original I'm
cautiously optimistic on it but I do see
the potential to go beyond what they the
confinements of the story and tell
things in different order and make
certain things have more of an impact
okay like that first 45 minutes for the
Ammi mission yeah was it blue ox
potatoes away right because it takes
like the first five minutes of the game
expense to 45 to an hour and it's
something that we all imagined as kids
that will if they take that with
liberties with the story when it comes
to Aris right whatever she know she's
going to die what if she has it worth it
create this false hope that man we make
we can save air at this time maybe she
doesn't have to die but what it were I'm
mad I think I'm a surname a go that way
today baby [ __ ] yeah if you want my
whole debt to pull that so like I said I
think then changing the ending of this
was was okay because for one it gets us
talking if this didn't happen if it was
the exact same ending we would be
sitting here talking about okay we know
what's gonna happen on this too
we're gonna go here we're gonna go here
go here this evenin
I think it's it's still more interesting
to keep 90 percent of the game the way
it is and change that little bitty 10%
because it keeps it keeps us guessing so
I don't I don't think 10 percent
necessarily could absolutely ruin the
game I think that champion sale is gonna
absolutely good I think that it's the
mission statement I think right I'll let
you go I apologize it was good I think
that 10% it wasn't like it was like not
directives direct they had you kill your
future selfs they killed they had you
kill to do creating the timelines and
upholding them now they Eva said at the
end of the game the unknown journey this
is not Final Fantasy 7 or eBay
I completely agree whew III think he's a
hundred percent right of being upset
because he was promoted this and he
bought this into thinking it's a remake
me on the other hand I was more open to
a different change so I'm a little bit
more open to the chain me gonna keep
them home being a Kingdom Hearts fan I'm
not easy they could screw this up
exactly exactly and that's where my
contention is I had no word they they
can screw this up pretty bad
if they don't go about it or write you
no way
fans having expectations the case may be
but say again that now people get four
people are actually into the weeds of
the theories and wasn't having part two
now y'all get why King of Hearts fans
get so hyped up and why we love these
connections and wide 100% hmm so that's
some of the people that are like guilt
is crazy how into part two does
everything right so what you're talking
to in me is a guy that has never been
satisfied with any connection or any
plot point or any crazy thing that
Kingdom Hearts has ever done let me
interrupt you there I I want to address
that and then I have to finish my
statement and I had to leave because I
have to go do something right okay the
reason people can't connect to Kingdom
Hearts is because it's not the timeline
changing it's not the intervention [ __ ]
they do on there it's the weird way that
they put out the games that you have if
you know what Kingdom Hearts one is
technically in the middle of the fret of
the timeline and that was the very first
game Brett the original game the one
that started all the time is a mobile
phone game so that's the reason a lot of
people don't understand what's going on
and you know once you play keno marts
wanted to like in order to understand
the kingdom horse franchise you have to
play all of them in and sit down and
think about what's going on you can't
just play them and not know it was hard
to bet into because it was on multiple
platforms so if you didn't have a veto
for a d/s or the playstation he was kind
of you know going back into the Final
Fantasy it's like I told Cognito I
completely understand why you know Hocus
is is upset because he was promoted this
this game for years and they didn't a
whole that's the reason it's called
remake and not remake Park one is
because they knew they were gonna
sniffing s you I personally feel like
Sephiroth is even gonna be the main
antagonist for these games anymore I
felt like that's the reason you fought
him so epic than this one is because
they won't or haven't you have that
fight again right I feel like
you gotta fight Sephiroth but I don't
think he's gonna be the final antagonist
you want my honest opinion no if you
want my honest opinion I think that
they're going to go more into the war
with the UH with you fees people in
Midgar because they kept talking about
that in there I feel like there if you
want my honest opinion I know this is
gonna be off the rails I think they're
going to have Genoa's race attacked the
planet do you think they're completely
debating an invasion then though right
right because I it's like I said like if
you look at it from the standpoint of
you know at the very end where they have
like the circle loop thing that they did
at the RIT at the end of the original
mm-hmm like it to me it felt like they
did that because they're like we're not
doing this again that's what it felt
like it felt like a troll like like
we're not doing this like partying a
prank yeah and I felt like the only
reason that they would have Sephiroth so
epic like that cuz I think that whole
fight was that broth was in c-clown's
mine I don't even think that was the new
realm of existence it was in a
singularity whatever the hell that means
because says he used the meteor like
there was too many things to make that a
real fight that was it that wasn't like
a realm that doesn't exist right he
didn't pick up the Shinra building and
throw it at us I there so you know I
feel like the only other thing that we
know uh obviously there could be some
plots that doesn't know of the only
thing narrative that we don't know that
the variable that we don't know that
they could take this game in is the
Nova's existence in her origin let me
let me ask you this before I pass though
what about alright wait we're getting
into infinity territory and my question
again another big shocker was I
obviously didn't play crysis core but i
think thank to you i HT KTB got me up to
speed
was the whole zach day and zach is alive
and Zach is not following you know
they're definitely follow another path
do let me ask you guys like do you think
we are going to they're going to
encounter themselves on this different I
didn't I'm okay into the we're gonna
have sweet yeah
we don't know how this is gonna work
it's like it's like huge this is final
fan this is Kingdom Hearts land this is
not is where eNOS has no problem making
people almost identical
they got no problem doing that okay when
they went to the town line I don't know
what that potentially meant they took
the people in that time line their
respective person in that time lines
place but part of me feels like that's
not the case I felt like there's another
cloud there's another there's there's a
one or another of everyone that went
through that time line including
Sephiroth I think I don't think they
should meet each other I think that they
should see glimpses into another time
line is actually made if your alternate
self is like super 90s b-list yes I
don't want to see that one disappear up
with if you want my honest opinion
mm-hmm without with Zack there we don't
know what kind of person clouds would
end up being cloud dying because that
dying is what it's what made my cloud is
what my destroy is what killed his mind
to make him think he was that for years
and if Zack is alive for all we know
that timeline of cloud could be evil
exactly yeah exactly that's that's more
like the possibilities are like kind of
like that crazy me each other can kind
of go pretty quite but again it could go
really wrong at the same time good lord
if cloud fights cloud I don't know I
really I really know I don't really I
really don't think they're gonna go that
far I just think they there's no reason
for us not to think that because they
didn't give us anything like that all we
know is they went into another timeline
where Zack is alive okay so no even even
in an ending area right there
is show cloud walking path sack in the
past that was the past that was
signifying that in that time because
that died before this the events of this
game it was showing that at that time in
the past he was walking on the same path
that they were in the future so when you
actually because then that's match them
up but but see that that's happening in
crisis called crisis core happened
before the events of this game yeah so
if they actually went back to Midgar I'm
willing to
choose a keys there no no I don't I
don't think so at all because regard so
regardless of how you view it on Zack is
dead seconds die
Zack his life was dead why you the exact
day barri
I'm curious that it shows that you know
he died with it the Shinra soldiers
killing him analyst but that was in
crisis it's no longer there but they
should be more with cloud like they he
survived it he's still alive yeah they
killed ain't they they show him walking
because cloud pretty much how cloud gave
prima that gave cloudless buses all
right yes I gotta remember it was the
buses sword in his back during when they
walk by no see after that fight after
that why he can't be dead after that
fight Zack go to his knees and fell on
his back and died right yeah he gave me
said carry my Larry my leg any reason
why the reason why cloud pretty much
took that person because the my co
poisoning and the genovian it it's that
literally like okay I'm this person in
the original game cloud is Zack didn't
even have the energy to put that sword
on his back he is very alive it looks
like it I don't know I don't think so so
what's your theory BG well let's do a
bend the knee on this we'll see we do in
a bit so the baby is is Zack alive
that's all exact alive yes in the same
world as this game yes graphic look he
is right and I think I think is he
realized he went so far back like I
don't think no I don't think that's part
of said frost plan I think that was just
a repercussion of what happened because
Sephiroth did what he did once I think
he don't you know double-check to like
make sure destroy Zack isn't alive and
there's no reason to fight faith with if
they're not gonna make significant
changes the mission thing yeah like they
even said the unknown Johnny knows it
look we know you love this
book this book we call final fantasy 19
1997 we know you love this book and they
threw that in the trash we ain't
listening and not only do they throw it
in the trash they said here's the book
how about you throw it you have to kill
fate and you have to listen to read 13
say oh my god if we fail here we have to
go play Final Fantasy you hope if you
remembered Reds vision when they all saw
the vision
Reggie vision was the original a big -
Final Fantasy 7 five years later they
said like what what was that he said
it's tomorrow's future if we felt it and
they did not tell Final Fantasy 7 please
help us do it I cannot feel more pranked
or troll ludonarrative dissonance you
talk about times and games where you
don't want to be doing what the game
tells you you need to do is that I
bought this Final Fantasy 7 remake I am
stoked about this this is fantastic now
kill it so here's the theory right let's
go I think I think it will die right I
don't think she's gonna die at the same
point she did she didn't need any
original right I think they're puffier
they're gonna make us since I believe it
oh she doesn't know that then she might
book she might realize oh the only way
we could win is I have to die so maybe
she doesn't die by willingly Aaron let
me let me technically don't have to die
alone she summons I let you know I'm
holy yeah let me throw this out
technically be Jean what happens if they
don't kill Aerith because oh I think
they're gonna they're gonna kill a party
member for that like that that that
moment that because they they want to
relive that to some point but I don't
think it's gonna be Earth I think you
Scott I think it's gonna be Tiffany this
time there's a really critical role in
going to Klaus mind and fairy a melon
hey so the thing is this cloud doesn't
need to do that he knows who he knows
the only reason he
being crazies because Sephiroth is
messing with it again if you take the
premise that Sephiroth knows what's
going on and not in time or whatever
there's no way he put cereth in the
lifestream so the main plot is probably
Aerith isn't in the live stream and then
the party has to kill her because they
have to put her there to hold III
disagree I disagree gomez because even
like near the end of the actual the
endings this game where cloud or
software goes up to cloud saying those
seven seconds were you gonna do with
them
yeah could it is he referring to the
time where no or between or hitting
planet and not nor or or could it be the
seven seconds that he could have saved
eros and all that after description
talks about meteor hitting planet in the
seven seconds it's in the chapter if you
don't beat sucks
if you don't be suffer often quick
enough at the end of the game the meteor
hits you and kills you down seven
seconds he counts it down so you know
yeah do you want you're gonna try to
save Aerith and lose the planet or you
gonna let her die I swear to god it's
gonna be you're gonna have to kill
Aerith yourself I know when that's not
Final Fantasy seven I can see that not
it's not it's definitely definitely
here's the thing what hold I know you
feel passionate about she's my thing is
the thing eyes true cloud cloud was
about to kill arif himself because he
was my Beeman over Genova Sephiroth came
out for not do it what what about what
about the theory of okay we we all know
slightly going off the rails here with
this unknown journey thing it's not a
one-to-one remake you know what about
you I say this pretty see your like for
the people that say okay you know what
this seems more like an adaptation right
we're taking the basic things of the
Final Fantasy 7 universe what you know
and love and now we are going to change
it my question is do you think there is
any way because I know how strongly you
disagree that day can redeem them and
give us a new interesting story and take
this characters in universe that would
get you to kind of say I don't
necessarily agree with them taking my
classic and doing manipulating it but
this is still told very well do you
think is any chance it could be solid
wood to you here's here's what I
compared this project to now and I think
you saw my tweet go out on this cutting
no but I view it as Game of Thrones and
I view it as I trust the people that
made Game of Thrones as long as they had
book material they were good at add up
to adapting that material I haven't been
fully satisfied with the modern
square-enix game in 15 years so when I
was pleasantly surprised to see was that
yeah you've got craziness in Final
Fantasy 7 remake but as long as they
were holding to the book of 1997 it was
more grounded than it usually is for
modern Aquarian X it was less convoluted
it was a simpler story of heroes and
villains and I think if you say we're
now going to do our own thing then I
have to instead of evaluating what
you've got as your source material from
1997 I wind up evaluating you against
Kingdom Hearts 3 lightning returns and
they are and so if I don't like those
things or fight they weren't I'll still
be buying Final Fantasy refresh and I
will buy it but it's not what I wanted
and oh do I think there's a chance
there's always a chance but a blind
squirrel finds a nut I'm done I could
love the next Nomura game it seems
unlikely but it's possibility because
it's a fantasy 7 not a chance in hell
and frankly I'm sick of meta contextual
astable gazing and beard stroking and
deciding what the nature of the Creator
is to his creation and talking about the
horrible shadows that look over his
shoulders or though to make an actual
Final Fantasy 7 game you don't want to
make it bud don't make it but don't wear
the skin suits right my favorite
characters I think took around to tell a
Kingdom Hearts story - III know where
you got it - the letter of the year -
the led like the true attorney a letter
of the law this was not what you
were promised you and me and worse it's
it's I I thought I had ten years of
looking forward to it right and now I
don't
okay okay here to think with your thing
with European ho good night from most
part I completely agree with you because
I am that Kingdom Hearts fan I am the
one I hide the first finger teen and
even in change to fifteen and I was
disappointed more or less by them I
enjoy my experience but looking back on
them yeah it could have been better it
could have been something greater with
587 to remake I feel like with that
classic can't be touched right mm-hm
it's it's pretty it's perfect in our
minds again that's a perfect game but
for us we just love it
the 7 remake it definitely hit that
notes of nostalgia and just storytelling
perfection we want it from Square Enix
for so long
yeah and even with like the in the
ending it's definitely tight you know
it's gonna be divisive and a lot of
people for me personally I
I love the possibility of where they can
go from here and there's a part of me
that's excited the weird way to you if
for like for like where they can go from
here and what other meta stuff that can
go with it again if you're not you know
like in hearts like storyline or
anything like that and yet right that's
gonna be nothing for you you're gonna be
upset and you're gonna be something that
you're gonna very hesitant on going for
and I can leave York that which is why
when I finish the game I was very
lukewarm mmm I was lukewarm on the
ending but the more I thought about it
and the more I like saw the connections
and saw where past care just were saying
certain things it didn't make sense the
first time and now they do it got me
really excited yeah you know I come off
as passionate and I come off as strong
and I'm a lawyer so one thing I want to
say here is that I don't begrudge a
single soul who loves that ending who's
excited about the future I don't I would
never ever tell anybody that likes
something to not like this of course
about what I'm but it you know I get to
that end and I say yeah you know I think
I've described it as the dream is dashed
I wanted to I wanted to be excited about
doing all those things on the end of
this one and just to write and I have a
high level of worry that not only are
they going to do it poorly they're going
to do it in the framework of what
I love and it's going to be grotesque
that definitely was in my mind when I
was writing my review for it I just I
went to the more optimistic route where
you're definitely more of like because
of their past games and I completely
understand it let me get let me get
boring man um this lady's ended bro like
what was going through your mind yeah
what was good what was going through my
mind is just like yeah I hate them with
the okay I'm I'm a pure if guy as well
what I'm a I love the original game I
love how the original game the story is
being told but I can't I can't be like I
say that didn't like how this story is
being told how you know the how the
ending was my biggest gripe with the
ending
if the Avalanche part we were Biggs and
that was my team that was mighty wedge
I'd you have to get trapped for a second
window yeah and we well yeah I think
they did that I was I was actually
thinking about that I think they
literally kept wedge alive just to try
to uh like first explaining the story of
of the whispers just to get the point
across again because when they when they
at the end when they the whispers grab
him there again showing you this one it
but he's not supposed to be here does
that be going max like I thought that's
what I thought that was mmm-hmm yeah
yeah but like even but like look at our
bigs you know the ending he got up he's
recovering I was like whoa I paid this
man I thought it was oddity on it when
you work we were getting too close yeah
exactly but you know as far the changes
with the with the ending I'm definitely
on the optimistic side well yeah I'm
also cautious as well because you know
when it's something that you do love you
kind of want it to you know sustain that
you know that perfection that you
remember the game and all right
so like I'm very optimistic of how the
story's gonna go I don't like that
they're you with the Zack thing
but you know what we're definitely gonna
see man I'm a very vocal do so I'll be
on Twitter at expiry that's question for
able to base that in reference to that
because you guys you and heck out of
Kingdom Hearts toots my question is what
did you feel when Sephiroth is doing the
Kingdom Hearts winged move and like he
didn't do any of that you know I went
when he did um heartless angel yo bro i
i lady really like was i 50% Hellfire oh
let me heal up cuz I know what's coming
though is coming in right right away
boom drop me to like 10 HP are they okay
this guy's nuts that counter stance did
that wait that conflict with you as the
Final Fantasy 7 purist or you love
Kingdom Hearts so much in his version of
that day I know the emerging things
right emerging games of different I like
the fact that they they implemented that
move code I think that move is is
basically like a it's it's a legendary
move like you know if a Kingdom Hearts
name but it's still very much tied to
suffer off you know okay you know the
angel witness the the name of the move
and all a this if you're not a Kingdom
Hearts fan you probably gonna have an
issue with it but III feel like it
didn't take away anything from me okay
personally it just added more like oh
they added this that's in Sue's Arsenal
that's really cool okay okay boy I mean
B G man yeah that's how I was just gonna
give in to some other stuff besides the
ending like the only thing one of the
one of the other things I didn't like or
there's bothered me a little bit was uh
and I guess it made sense for the
stories sake it's the fact that you know
how any original when you got to Shinra
and you got to other upper levels and
everything like that the ambience and
atmosphere
it was literally a horror movie yeah the
lighting is insane yeah the original
lead-ups like set for off and everybody
was like what the hell is going on they
get a blood trail trails
and Sark the blood trails even they even
switch up the type of enemies you run
and so I was like this is dark fine you
don't get the same like horror scene
type thing in the new one which I
understand why but like I missed it it
was that besides besides that I mean
dis Wanda final fantasy usually isn't my
favorite because there were some parts
where you know due to storytelling they
had a lot of you know in-game cutscenes
and I feel like sometimes it just
interrupted the flow of gameplay I was
like just let me fight stop stop into
interrupting me I get it
let me fight and everything like that
and just air with yourself I've
explained my gripes with every I well I
think Aerith exists for nothing other
than a story plot character cuz like she
is useless otherwise I just don't like
like she's trash the trash in the
original and everybody uses that against
that is Opie in the remake in the
original G trash she's got she's moved a
tray of whatever was she does that
focused light Oh to rate their way of
judgment move is the art when bro arcade
win is so broken because you could cast
magical spells like
you can see beyond burial one oh my he
wrote your people in that circle that
the ATB circle and you just keep flowing
with it with it with the limits with
with with what she with her pluses she
doesn't hurt her pluses do not like
certify her as how to fly it just
doesn't it just doesn't verify her to be
worth that the character slap that she's
in over Tifa or bury it does you know
why parents pros are way better than
than errors yeah you know sir Pro would
arif her magic potency is so much more
effective than berry or teef like we do
he'll like you got me where to go for
that he'll you like we got magic for old
for everything or almost everything air
we can do this material for that when
you play you we got Barry for that you
need you need here we got cure for that
when you play when you play hard mode
and um like I know you playing hard mode
now I don't know if you get to arif yet
but yo when you you hear what Barry it
would be like 25% Aerith it'd be 75%
you're crazy
Ward's a fire oh yeah I pretty much make
Barrett is the tank right like even when
I'm in my first playthrough he had like
7,000 HP while everybody oh yeah and I
thought that's a faster fact because
because I put HP up on him so I put HP
up on him and I give him
I give him revival and I give him cure
and some others so because he's the one
I can guarantee you he's not gonna die
like never died I think always I'll pick
I'm gonna heal everybody else you know
so I don't need air if that's why that's
why I don't like I just feel like she's
she doesn't she doesn't mess with your
you know arcane win if I don't like and
on top of that is just that when you
compare like if we consider her like a
support you know character healing buff
character when you compare her to other
others other characters like her in
other RPGs she is that good oh come on
bro come like like I play like when you
play like even like drag I play Dragon
Quest like a year or two ago like the
healing characters in that game approach
they make her look like like they learn
they they learn moves that nobody else
could can can learn for one thing so
they're invaluable right and it's not
like they're not like Limit Breaks for
like abilities they're just like things
they can do right like with with with
whether it's buffs like attack up
defense up hey oh oh that's your limit
break
oh these a regular moves for us that is
that she's not for you
for you it's clearly all I would say is
get that that I forgot the name of the
weapon that gives that um like I said if
ray of judgment if you want to make her
a little bit more offensive I thought
that was super powerful cleaner than the
me from I think the rounded one yeah the
round ignition with that as a trip it's
a trip it's definitely a trip there's no
doubt about it
but with flow but that moving it sort of
day off but if you get that off it is
something crazy you know I thought what
prey was but she had started off even
though it's a materially can get yes
what's that other move that the the
shield one that is op2 brothers against
dream wave
Jenova dream wait what well I I have so
much little shield but let me ask you a
question okay so knowing that get the
full cast of Final Fantasy seven rice go
okay let's say let's say in a situation
where Arif doesn't die
how many of you are keeping keeping her
in the party when you could choose
anybody the CAHSEE if I see you do like
near like after you beat the game
she is so helpful with planet protection
and when it is actually a planet
inflation oh yeah there's a Coliseum
where there's like a 2v2 fight I brought
teeth on Eris with me because eras one
could do that healing do a bunch of that
magic while teeth let's definitely that
quick fist fighter that gets a grant
he's quick but are you keeping her
Barrett everybody else in a full you
could choose from all of them are you
keeping her in he may be right on it you
your baby your baby on this I gotta give
you the audience of therefore the
healthy thing is like the remake they
made Arif so much more useful but I
gotta keep much as I like her I don't
know if I will keep like with Vincent
comes and and all these other people and
now we get but can we can we say no
shout out to red being kind of low-key
useless and no red with staggering
people for me bro save them in that part
it's okay he was doing Limit Breaks I
was like you keep doing the Starlight
outside yo thank you um you feed that's
my that's my chick - yes it's my guy
that basically the dragoon of 5:57 yeah
so let me jump in real quick it awaited
we would go along but um look at the
other day my feeling was okay like Bari
said we are not my mama's final fantasy
right now Abby's here we are doing
something completely different
um and what's crazy is I'm a purist so
generally when people do stuff like this
and you start messing around
source material you start forcing your
own little agendas I'm usually like hold
I'm actually surprised by cuz I thought
I was gonna have that feeling at first
you know so where I'm at now is you know
this is uncharted territory they have to
protect you to completely ruin this yes
but there is a part of me that is
excited for a story I don't know what is
gonna happen you know I'm saying there's
a it's a little part of me that's like
Yodas this could be cool because it this
could if they pull it off and get it you
know yes I shouldn't go no no I just
wanna ask a simple question cuz I I can
totally understand it could be cool
mm-hmm if it's cool
yes outside of the lack of surprise
which I think we over value in a society
in general talking about spoilers and
things of that nature but outside of the
lack of surprise do you think even a
cool story would wind up better more
resonant more fulfilling more emotional
but this is my take on it I feel this
part would in by a period they they told
Final Fantasy already the whole thing I
feel this is the new new part to ord is
the new loop when I when the credits
come up it it says the untold journey
awaits you have now told me we are
breaking the script but we doing what we
want to do like yeah when they get down
with the project right and we we look
back and that's it maybe we say it's a
good it's a good story
hey that wasn't terrible right what are
the chances in your mind of that good
story being better than what Moe has
very low and you make I really I agree
that the chances are completely in your
favor for them the botched is to do
ridiculousness absolutely no I'm saying
it's good I'm saying they make a good
game they make a good name I don't fancy
700k okay I don't I don't compare them
because I look at this as an adaptation
I look at this is the different grip I
look at the riders saying to themselves
chance to have the remake right so I
think the right comparison point is at
the end of all this we don't get that
thing right even if it's good would it
have been that good see I look at things
more holistically I try to think of
things 10 years down the line this is
the project that we got right and
comparing it to the project that we
thought we were getting what we could
have had based on what they demand the
dream
holy fun wrote about a difference where
I disagree with you they've already day
completely demonstrating to me
throughout this whole game we are
breaking protocol they keep reminding
you your family thought this is gonna
happen but no yeah that's that's that's
what I got to because like the whole the
whole thing with the game is that
everything has changed pretty much like
the the lead-up to the results the
results is kind of the same they're like
okay this story be happening within
magar this story be happy with my car
but the lead-up to everything or has
been completely different you know me so
that's what I'm going with was the
that's the next part I think I feel like
if they change so much they they're
definitely gonna lose that that that
hardcore fanbase is like the pure it the
hardcore and the people who thinking
this is a legit remake that would they
definitely needed every line that's
that's gonna connect it's a lie it's a
bait and switch
I could completely support and
understand you hope or anyone that says
did you have this is not mine
you cannot throw remake on this and say
this is the same game I understand that
I completely do it I definitely that
feeling I definitely can understand in
resonate from me when I when I was going
through it it just felt like yo this is
the story we want to tell if we had more
time and we had our creative freedoms to
do what we want that's the vibe I'm
getting from them that's what that's
what he actually said in an interview
they was like this is the story pretty
much that they wanted to tell but due to
like technical days or I don't know I
don't know if that's PR or that that's
what 96 they didn't want to tell a story
about time travelinggoats controlling
fate I mean I think that's clear the new
admission I agree with that that that
was the whole ghost thing definitely cut
threw me off for a little bit I wasn't
sure I really liked them play their
purpose was so that they can tell the
story how they want to tell it without
be constrained by the pier the pier
story that we have there one thing
though for because you said that will
they have the same emotional resonance
will have the same impact how did you
feel for the first 31
I was the game you're playing loved it I
told you 15 out of 10
yeah yes so so from from that right
there I feel like we could have any bit
about your kind of faith exactly exactly
no because I think I would say fit the
15 out of 10 the first thirty four and a
half hours if using the book material
and adapting it the half hour that I got
to see there was a lot of where we
fought a gigantic tornado man in a black
hole before arriving at the edge of
creation and like talking about a meteor
in a weird way is what I can expect as
the quality of writing so you have no
faith that it would what they was always
gonna do that okay we're holding to the
book now you we're gonna show off what
we can do on our own and we're gonna do
more of that on our own and I like you
even with a vendor's endgame right we're
like some people hated it other people
loved it because it's like that timeline
time travel route and a lot of you're
just not gonna vibe with this I can I
get that now BJ I gotta ask you this so
like be the overall with what was
presented this ending what is your
feeling on this ending how did you walk
away from this I'm good I really don't
have like many that many gripes with
their direction they chose to go and
like I said if they keep it 90 percent
you know accurate even if it's like this
different timeline thing I'm okay with
it uh I think I think they could still
make the game whole you know with
whatever direction they choose to go I
think we'll be fine I'm surprised I fear
I feel they're gonna have a said the
lead up who's gonna be different but the
result is still gonna thank you that's
how I see it I feel I feel like it's
it's a puff fake and so it's like okay
panicking wait we got choice hoping I
got you I said I'm okay and I'm just
gonna tell you and that's fair that's
this is just opinions now right yeah I
can't imagine I can't imagine going
through the effort of being so hard
about we're not gonna go to that future
we're gonna fight fate we're gonna end
that future thanks alive pigs is alive
we
do something entirely different on
results we're gonna tell a different
story and so that's one of the
discussions I've seen online is that all
maybe it's gonna be minor maybes give me
90 percent the same maybes gonna be the
same as the remake no I don't think so
at all and I think you are gonna get
that from the next title I jokingly said
reframe that's what I expect I expect
them to be saying okay remake is clearly
the subtitle it's not a descriptor and
it's gonna be reframed and it's gonna be
exactly what gets a whole new title cuz
they go laughs I'd be almost willing to
guarantee it Klaus about the face all
Sephiroth and then bear it's like on
your left if we if we get a like a berry
green the Buster Sword Oh
Zach's like yeah I got thank you thank
you for we're so so hallelujah how many
parts do we think is remaining three I
think we're gonna have three total three
total parts PG yeah I think three unless
they take a really long time to put out
- yeah it's probably gonna be three mm
if they're if they're puttin the
attention to detail like they did with
make gar into each town you know me I
know I know me behind is gonna get a lot
you know Cosmo candy is gonna get a lot
yeah you know the me I'm not sure
everything's in it whole thing is a
complete departure he's like oh don't
get your hopes up
I mean I think the stuff is there in the
world that they can use for whatever
story they want to tell now and then
they'll use those assets as they see fit
but I don't know that Cosmo Canyon is a
guarantee I don't a gold saucer
temple of ancients I think has to be but
maybe not I'm who know the thing is what
Cosmo can I think it's there because
they hinted it with the Cosmo theater
you know that's pretty much the same
technology that you have in a the Cosmo
Canyon which you know they probably
Lincoln that oh we took shinra's
technology now we have the the whole
planetarium thing here in our in our
Canyon but mm hey I think it'd be great
but but you know I don't I don't think
there's any guarantees I think they are
trying to establish I said elsewhere
online on this that you do that right at
the end you do the 34 and a half hour
then you hit up with all of that really
in one half-hour right before the ending
of your game in a state where you know
it's gonna be at least two years
probably more before than that entry
because it's essentially giving the bad
news and running out of the room
I almost feel that way hole yeah I would
show and hey this is there's gonna be a
negative first from people like me and
that'll dissipate as all passion and and
then when we're showing off you
characters and some new places hope
you'll be back out of vogue available at
marketing the thing is the thing is like
I don't think nobody here really
disagree like I understand completely
where your your your rights are yeah you
know because like I'm kind of deer with
you but I'm just saying like you're
optimistic I went it was it was still
good like like well marvel universe
Marvel movies they changed the whole
continuity all the time but the movie
itself is not good so I'm like okay I
can't get down with Ari I'm we caught a
movie you're not good that's what's
giving me hope because like after you
said it great those for you [ __ ] what
about you felt about that the first 35
minutes right this was the most this is
literally my you know the game of the
year like I'm like this is amazing like
now I wasn't I
it was so well done and I'm like if the
this director and this this team has
given me this level of enjoyment and I'm
not saying that I'm not one hopes I
would say I completely fell to the last
five minutes or whatever it was horrible
but if y'all gave me this I gotta give
you a little faith and benefit of the
doubt that whatever you got left to tell
can still be that's what I'm holding on
no I think that's fair I view it as them
saying we're not gonna do that anymore
so it's it's just a difference of
opinion as to what's gonna happen and I
don't know that any of us can get into
new Moroz or any of the other you know
leads on this their minds but it seems
to me like you go through that effort
you go through that production to say
it's gonna be really different what you
just saw was different and and if we
didn't think that was good enough if we
didn't think that was different enough
then we wouldn't need to go through all
this after all the show to have me fight
fate because a lot of stuff did change
in the
already 35 hours he played and that
wasn't strong enough we need to go and
kill a giant my thing is that I just
feel like I don't think the whole the
whole Watchmen of fate the whole
whisperers are completely out the way
and I felt like may sound corny here
well maybe that's like a small you know
batch of them because if they're if
they're hinting towards that these are
like you know go stuff like that cetera
the agents there's no way that's gonna
be all of them they're you know what I
think I saw at the end and there's a lot
of flash and weirdness is that you get
out until the arbiter the whispers are
kind of leaderless Sephiroth whatever
version of him takes them all into
himself giving this symbolism of he is
destiny now and he has his own fate and
then you have a mental fight he talks to
you on the edge of a you know a rock
thing in space and and then you go on
your go forward into the unknown
adventure but he has all the power of
fate that it whispers are in him the
whispers are no more they the ones that
were around in the past and elsewhere
all dissipated every other whisper is in
Sephiroth he controlled his own fate and
that's the fight
yeah it showed that he was like kind of
controlling cuz that's what the
Harbinger came from that he controlled
him like I want you to attack these guys
here you know meaning for what what
these men look two hours job we talked a
while didn't expect I go to or I think I
could go but I don't do people got shout
out to y'all for coming last minute you
know on the spoiler cash out to the chat
man you guys on fire with everybody's
get everybody's last little take as far
as on you know the next game is game
which you had getting in arm as far as
where people can find your stuff so heck
excited not excited for the next game
and then also sign and I wake up people
find you know all that stuff oh yeah I'm
super pumped for it super fun for the
next part where they're gonna go for
from here again cautiously optimistic
because I love the original and they
definitely the potential to mess us up
just like with the remake itself but
other than that I'm excited you guys to
catch my review actually a final 57 will
make on Lords of gaming net I go full
detail into it and and I also got the
score on there so yeah good should go
check that out you can follow me on
twitter hector underscore ram roman
numeral two so i hi you catch me there
right more
articles W to get more to file fancy
seven because there's definitely a lot
more to talk about those now you know
Subaru pulling up definitely at the
roundtable and of course my brother Jay
Bari this is I had you over definitely
appreciate you in a minute man yeah man
passionate candid on the PlayStation
nation as well so real thing you know
real quick off overall excitement non
excitement for the next one and also
where can people find you oh yeah I'm
super excited for the next one you know
I can't wait man like I'm playing this
game over and over again like hard
motives if it's good man it's really
really good I'm towing fees brother oh
yeah I'm definitely platinum in this
that's a fact but yeah it was I
definitely appreciate the invite it was
definitely a fun conversation you know
having different you know points of view
on the game but overall I you know I can
say everybody enjoyed the game overall
you know personally is my game of the
year I know you got you seen it Twitter
it all says laugh yeah everything yeah
man you can find me Jay underscore Bari
T away or J I think J bar underscore to
you it my bad I know my own well yeah
well I will be doing another like
spoiler cast as well on my channel okay
I'm just waiting for like you know
certain people to finish the game they
don't know that you know if I post
pictures and I waited a week to post
pictures guys I don't care we spoil it
or not you know you guys haven't played
this game before me you know a lot of
people got this game physical they
played it before me but they complain
about me about spoiling my friend one
thing last night Square Enix stop
blocking the ps4 capture with the last
ball fight come on yeah but they must
have a time limit on that right they
block the last two fights man but I'm
definitely God I'll capture that I'm
gonna capture that man they did that
with 15 but the question is did they
ever relinquish dad blockage at one
point okay like can I go to Final
Fantasy 15 at the end again try to
screen cap and put it up it might be
Mike it might go to hoax point it's such
a drastic change but they didn't what is
this leaking out to everybody I guess I
think
can lift the restrictions I think
squared XK like crazy with fairbell fit
and of course the leader of the weapon
whale podcast my man BG man good to have
you pull up in the round you already
know you know tell me about how excited
are not excited you are about the part -
of remakes last refrain and where do
people come back oh yeah I can't wait
for the next game I mean I'm working on
hard mode right now I'm going for the
Platinum this is it's not actually a
difficult Platinum especially if you
love the game it's not a difficult
latinum yeah the most challenging thing
might be the getting the list of enemy
skills that might have like the most
challenging thing but that's just like
biloba tedious but uh yeah I'm going for
the plaka last platinum I went for was
like 2017 well horizon zero dawn so that
just that's just like how much I'm
enjoying this game so I'm gonna get the
plat and I yeah I can catch up weapon
wheel podcasts Sundays at 6:30 yes
laughs you already know sloop rubber
that's what's up and of course the
spiciest of all takes Bob Baer Hogan law
in the building bringing the smoke
loving what he was bringing to the table
with some fantastic points man so first
of all are you excited or even
purchasing remakes last refrain could
the people fight well as I said I think
it's I would be lying if I said there
was much of a chance that I won't be
purchasing it whenever it comes out I
have to be honest about these things so
I'm not the guy that they're trying to
get on the margin to convince them to
buy something with Final Fantasy on the
label I'm a sucker
outside of that yeah you know when I'm
not just talking about Final Fantasy on
either Twitter or pod yes I do law here
in Southeast Michigan and I have a
youtube channel that most prominently
has a series called virtual legality
where we talk about the business and law
of pop culture most often video games
movies TV things along those lines one
of the ones that we had that's pretty
popular is we went through the streaming
restrictions on what you can stream and
not stream with respect to Final Fantasy
7 remake and how that was impacting
people that had the game earlier than
April 10th I think on April 3rd in
Australia and so we talked about those
things all the time you can find that at
YouTube
calm /ho blah and you can also talk to
me whenever you like as long as you
don't mind a lot of Final Fantasy tweets
on Twitter also at home ah yo salut home
and definitely thank you for pulling up
man fantastic a view are always great to
have all different sides of this feeling
your tweets will bind your mental I was
like I have to you were the inspiration
to push me to end this game and are nuts
after Tuesday night yeah Oh bro yeah it
was a timeline yeah it was it was crazy
I had to Butte people add to just get
off be dark for a while it's just try to
blow up this thing yo my time line muted
everything yeah I couldn't I couldn't
afford that but um yes look to that
salute to you guys we'll pull it up man
this is fantastic like I said for me you
already know it is not coming in on
Twitter and all that stuff yes I will be
getting remake reframe there is a little
bit of it there's a little bit of
excitement to see where they go to go
with this thing that's all I got man
everybody look enjoy guys please yeah I
just want to say first of all thank you
[ __ ] for the invite
and again it's a pleasure to talk with
all you guys about this because growing
up I never they had a lot of people talk
about with filefish my sister was not
the gamer dad mom no way my feelings on
the game so I really appreciate this
discussion going deep dad Final Fantasy
uh again thank you so much for having me
you already know brother had to have you
man look everybody enjoy your day we
bought out of here you know I love
podcast tomorrow Sunday 1:00 p.m. we
don't hate you with this outro and we
out catch you guys later
[Music]
[Music]